para analizar este comienzo de campaña y
la temporada que se le puede venir a Los
Ángeles Lakers contactamos con la ciudad
de alajuela en Costa Rica para conversar
con el periodista deportivo Luis Enrique
Acosta Saludos Luis Enrique Buenas
noches para usted Gracias por estar con
nosotros en Francia 24 aprovecho y le
pregunto qué expectativas podríamos
tener con esta campaña de la NBA o Mejor
aún podrá Golden State reeditar el
título hay mucha expectativa de cara lo
que va a hacer esta temporada de la NBA
30 equipos que lograron armar muchos o
proyectos muy pero muy interesantes de
Cara a lo que va a ser esta zafra una
zafra bastante bastante importante
partiendo del vigente monarcanon de esta
competencia como son los golden este
warriors un equipo que logra mantener su
seno de jugadores importantes de cuando
hablamos del seno de jugadores
importantes allí de la cabeza de Bob
marleyers cuando hablamos de Bob Marley
el gerente general que sabe que el
impuesto de lujo le está jugando una
mala pasada están por encima del tope
salarial Y tuvo que hacer algunos
ajustes para mantener jugadores de la
categoría de Stephen curry de Clayton
son el propio Green en la presencia de
Jordan también andrews es un equipo de
constelación de jugadores de altísimo
nivel también ahora James wiseman de que
por fin está sano este interno joven de
Jonathan cominga algunos jugadores ese
que tuvieron que partir desde esta
franquicia ganadora una franquicia
ganadora en el último lustro de la NBA
también tomando en consideración lo que
es la participación ahora de jugadores
como donster y vincenzo y Jamaica el
Green que han llegado para cubrir
algunos escenarios el que dejan
jugadores como otro Porter Junior que
partió hasta el equipo de Toronto
raptors también de Second que ahora está
comporta Trailblazer Entonces es un
equipo que está muy muy bien ensamblado
y para esto para buscar revalidar el
título ojo también una conferencia del
oeste con una franquicia como Los
Ángeles Clippers esta franquicia que
siempre le está faltando algo tienen a
cabo el Leonard sano para el arranque
John Walker tiene muchísimo tiempo sin
jugar baloncesto pero que son piezas y
uno de las franquicias que tiene una
planilla muy pero muy larga una planilla
muy muy amplia de jugadores que podrían
estar dando la talla Memphis le dice
Dallas Mavericks en la conferencia del
este por supuesto No hay que olvidar a
conjuntos como Brooklyn nets también el
propio equipo de Filadelfia 76 r también
milwaukeeboks y ojo con Cleveland and
cavaliers Luis pero hablamos hace poco
del mal inicio que han tenido los Lakers
en la actual campaña que se puede
esperar de este conjunto por lo que
resta del año me parece una interrogante
bastante bastante
peculiar vamos a llamarla de esta manera
Luis Alberto Amigas y amigos de Francia
el 24 en español Los Ángeles Lakers que
vienen de una temporada horrorosa es una
temporada bastante bastante complicada
quisieron rearmar el proyecto se les
hizo muy muy muy complicado yo creo que
la presencia de Russell Westbrook en el
equipo termina Que siendo una presencia
negativa más que positiva para este
conjunto no pudieron salir de él es un
jugador que está ganando más de 40
millones de dólares no es apetecible
para el mercado es un jugador que está
viviendo su peor época en la NBA más
allá de que todavía dejan registros en
materia ofensiva Interesante pero creo
que no hay ese matrimonio con Anthony
Davis gol propio Lebron James llega
Dennis Shooter este elemento alemán que
tuvo una un eurobasket formidable casi
logra llevar a su equipo Alemania a las
grandes finales Pero es un equipo que le
va a faltar un equipo que no lo veo
entrando en los playoffs Creo que van a
estar allí tal vez luchando por el
playing pero van a pasar muchos dolores
de cabeza estos Ángeles Lakers además de
la presencia de un entrenador nuevo un
entrenador que tiene que saber cómo
cohesionar
que ya está sano también este ex Miami
Heat la presencia de Patrick Beverly un
jugador que más duro a la defensa algo
que adoleció bastante el equipo de Los
Ángeles Lakers en la temporada pasada
pero de verdad que no lo juro nada
extremadamente positivo a este conjunto
de Los Ángeles Lakers ojalá me esté
equivocando porque es un equipo que
tiene muchísima afición va a depender
mucho de lo que haga Lebron James y
Anthony Davis Amén de que se mantengan
sanos Recuerden que ya en la temporada
número 20 para LeBron en el máximo
baloncesto del planeta y Anthony Davis
es un jugador con muchísima tendencia a
lesionarse